é podia todos
meu nome é pedro fui estudando no design
civil no liceu disse que o técnico no
campo da alameda e isso o atleta
olímpico da natação
venho eu já começava a aparecer a
oportunidade de estar com vocês a
partilhar um pouco da minha experiência
é vamos falar um pouco daquilo que se
chama o curso enquanto estudante
universitário e agora um pouco enquanto
trabalhador e tudo aquilo que foi um
erro em evolução no esporte e o modo
como esporte me ajudou na formação
acadêmica e o mesmo o modo como a
formação acadêmica me ajudou muito forte
o tempo o tema da festa deste teto era
seu limite e no fundo é assim que eu
vejo um pouco é a minha forma de estar
nunca dou por e por garantidas as coisas
são diz aí vai ser um caso complicado
não isso nunca ninguém fez isso eu quero
porque não há por que não tentar é e e
assim que eu penso que tem nos últimos
anos é vivido um pouco sempre sempre
pode impor como como componente da minha
formação minha tudo no esporte sempre
achei que a minha atitude forte ea ter
uma atitude perante ea ser lhe ia ter
consequências daquilo que era a minha
atitude perante a vida e portanto as
situações do cotidiano e isso e por isso
faz de mim uma série de defensor do que
o tipo é é um segundo componente da
formação acadêmica
olha pra trás eu conseguir uma o curso
desde que entrei pode ter sobre o
técnico e comecei a participar em
competições internacionais
entrementes é eu comecei a nadar aos 11
anos na altura estava em obra e até lá
eram um normal do atleta tanto
participar em competições nacionais e
tinha bom aproveitamento escolar não
nada
na área há até que hoje 18 anos é teve
próprio técnico eo tempo lisboa e também
aproveitei para andar próximo corte em
que o meu clube de coração e então foi
previsto um desafio bastante bastante
complicado dessa cidade com o clube de
outra dimensão e está no técnico você
achava espero que hoje ainda ou seja é
exigente e foram dança
vou falar foi a compra foi de 2007 até
2010 altura em que termina aí
a partir desse setor
gosto do meu horário tanto né na altura
é estar assim todas as semanas e
portanto eu fazia questão de estar em
todas em todas as aulas porque percebi
que ao mínimo descuidos a mínima
distração eu ia perder é o rito oriental
tentava captar a maior parte da
informação que podia saber que
precisamos não ia ter tempo e ter o
mesmo horário e até mesmo a mesma carga
de trabalho e trans e então este fez com
que tivesse começado a ser extremamente
organizado para conseguir é fazer tudo
aquilo que eu queria
uma das coisas que quero dizer que antes
era sem dúvida os treinos da manhã não
sei se são natação
nós fazemos trans e meia da manhã
e nessa altura é a idéia por trás da
manhã era extremamente desafiante porque
eu tinha que acordar por volta das 5 5 e
mais 5 e 20 para apanhar o primeiro
autocarro que passava na rua para
conseguir chegar a horas atrás e depois
era uma correria a sair do treino e
tentasse a técnicas oito e por aí fora a
tarde era o que nós sabemos é tentar
ajudar mas um som do gramado tentando
aproveitar porque sabia que muitos dos
20 semanas não ia ter provas e sem
dúvida
esta campanha da oposição eficiência
tecnologia como também vocês algumas
chave no técnico
acabamos por alternar entre manhã e
tarde e e todo esse processo no segundo
ano foi outra vez complicado tive que
adaptar a tudo aquilo que era o meu
horário sempre de acordo com os treinos
do sporting e nesse aspecto se for
também fez adaptar às várias situações
que aparecem e hoje em dia
dou muito valor é a isso não só na
esperança de trabalho como no cotidiano
muitas muitos dos meus colegas
procuravam os usuários a tarde termina
mais tarde manhã para eu resolvi treinar
mais manhã até um pouco mais tarde para
para aproveitar essa essas manhas sabia
que sabia que ia ser difícil e foram
semanas consecutivas consecutivas
é com o mesmo horário no esporte
muitos muito nossas forças só serei
passado semanas assim como assim como a
nossa formação acadêmica nós que
passamos dois três meses quatro meses a
estudar para o exame e muito fortes
isso é uma coisa nós passamos semanas
semanas inteira sem treinar me sentindo
dor cansaço temos que dar sempre mais
pra depois estarão os às vezes um dia ou
uma hora vai sem dúvida que isso isso ao
longo de semanas e semanas e antes
é complicado nós acabamos por saudar
valor o tempo quando realmente não temos
vai pois estes anos de 63 anos intenso
em que comecei a participar em
competições internacionais conseguiram
propor os mundiais de natação em 2008
2009 a acabar o curso em 2010 é a
cobrada para que se tornem 2010
no fundo eu ouvia aquilo que é
o objetivo dos anos é um dos atletas
querem os jogos olímpicos eu queria nos
jogos olímpicos é ea questão era como
como é que eu ia fazer com esta
quantidade de coisas e então achei por
bem e até muito contrariamente ao que
sozinho família e todos achavam depois
aquele esforço todo tentar fazer tudo
eram casos é desperdício
eu resolvi passar os dois anos de de
mestrado para 3 inscrevi-me só a dois
terços das cadeiras propositadamente
para conseguir ter mais tempo para
treinar para conseguir até dedicar mais
aos estudos e e e ter realmente
aproveitar aquela oportunidade que é
tirar um mestrado foram novamente
outro contraste nas piores complicados
porque o fundo tem muito de rotina mas
nós queremos chegar ao topo
temos consciência diferente e temos que
todas as alturas mesmo sabendo que a
rotina é sempre a mesma diferenciar-nos
e e conseguir fazer coisas diferentes
fazer algo que nós não fizemos até agora
é muito mais fácil que eu estou aqui por
nós vamos entrar no e nossa faz questão
disse
e no fundo é essa fase se sentia muito
isso não espero resultados diferentes
fazendo tudo da mesma maneira e este é
digamos um período em que eu adotei como
como espírito santo tentar ser diferente
tentar fazer as coisas de maneira
diferente outra outra frase que o que eu
gosto muito que é no fundo aquilo que
era um pouco a rotina mas tinha que se
fazer diferente
dança é o trabalho deles faixa depois de
trabalhar do que fez no fundo era isto
era eu
na altura estava a terminar a minha tese
e após trás e pensar na oi tem que fazer
qualquer coisa ainda não estava aqui eu
não tava eu tenho que aprofundar mais um
pouco eo mesmo instante
ok eu treinava estou a andar bairro mas
tem que ser mais eu tenho que conseguir
mais e no fundo esse é essa espírito de
preservar essa ajudou muito
ambas as partes
finalmente é terminar este curioso
conseguir terminar a minha formação
acadêmica e conseguir fazer mesmo progex
de londres foi uma experiência incrível
é é a melhor competição na melhor
competição do mundo pouca exposição dos
atletas que lá chegam e sem dúvida
olhando para trás fez com que isto tudo
vale a pena passar deste este este
curioso também combinou com um dos meus
grandes objetivos que era quero ser o
melhor a nível africano que o conseguiu
em 2015
é esse essa prestação no campeonato
africano fez com que terminemos projetos
de do rio e está ainda ante um ano antes
dos jogos até 2015
tudo fazia crer que desta vez já não
tendo toda a estreia de apresentar até
se acabar as canárias e tudo e ter uma
boa preparação calma pra provável mas
não surgiu a oportunidade de de arranjar
um trabalho que me dava para conciliar
minimamente as questões do trainee todas
as deslocações postagens condições de
coração e eu resolvi
ganhar essa oportunidade e dizer porque
não treinar após jogos e trabalhar ao
mesmo tempo não era o que muitos dos
meus colegas natação
diziam que querem vencer porque gostavam
e era complicado eles não eu vou
conseguir
é questão de organizar é a função deles
é possível eu vou tentar e ea de
conseguir esse foi conseguir conseguir
fazer uma boa prestação no olympique se
sem dúvida muito por causa da em todo o
percurso é dou muito valor às pessoas
que acompanhem as falhas da equipa
as faculdades sem dúvida que que o apoio
delas é o oposto do de todo o grupo de
trabalho é muito importante para o nosso
sucesso individual é é a natação como
sabe é um esporte individual mas o
sporting eu do dono graças a isso um
clube com grandes atletas faz com que
todos os indivíduos aumente tenham
melhores resultados sem dúvida o
coletivo é muito importante e pronto
agora que está o que coloque toda a
gente muitas vezes colocam na fase
terminal das câmeras dos dois atletas é
onde parar e o ou continuar um pouco um
pouco x ciências palavras descrevem
aquilo que que a atitude que devemos ter
na no esporte na vida
a ambição alguma certa loucura uma
creche uma determinação em conseguir
ainda mais depois depois destes deste
percurso dentro mundiais jogos olímpicos
a record sem sinais a mim é que o que eu
faço como definição de vencer essa
dúvida é a oportunidade de continuar
ainda altar entanto tudo aquilo que
passou da experiência e do conhecimento
nós temos sempre que olhar pra frente e
olhar para o próximo objetivo e ainda
não não
estará feita na suíça por que não tentar
outros outros horizonte e em continuar o
esforço pra mim é tem sido um grande
exemplo para mim é uma família nem
sempre quando a minha formação acadêmica
e enquanto trabalhador e sem dúvida que
recomendo a todos é que façamos fortes e
que surgiram as cidades na vossa na
nossa carreira futura
obrigado
[Aplausos]